tout commence le 4 novembre 2021 lorsque
kaïra Amraoui milieu de terrain du PSG
violemment agressé par un commando deux
personnes agresses violemment kaïraoui
avec une barre de fer en visant
particulièrement ses membres inférieurs
très vite une personne est suspectée
d'être la commanditaire de cette attaque
et sa coéquipière Aminata Diallo qui
souhaitait les vincer du groupe et
prolonger son contrat après de longs
mois d'enquêtes l'affaire connaît un
rebondissement vendredi dernier
si cette histoire a connu un coup
d'accélérateur c'est grâce à la
découverte de messages envoyés à ses
proches et révélée par la presse le 17
septembre ce que je veux c'est jouer à
sa place être sélectionné en équipe de
France je vais me rapprocher d'elle en
étant gentil pour mieux lui prendre sa
place de titulaire des messages
troublants mais aussi des recherches
internet incriminantes elle cherche
cocktail de médicaments dangereux ou
encore casser une rotule présumée
innocente Aminata risque aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 10 ans de prison pour violence à
graver et associations de malfaiteurs
toutes les révélations exclusives sur
l'affaire Aminata Diallo ce soir dans
TPMP
dans un instant nous aurons donc
l'avocat d'Aminata Diallo qui vient
souvent nous voir un mois de bâti voilà
qui sera là qui a été choisi par Aminata
et nous sommes avec Ronan Folgoas
journaliste qui a fait des révélations
incroyables dans Le Parisien qui connaît
toute cette affaire merci Ronan d'être
là merci beaucoup merci le 4 novembre à
Minata Diallo ramène Kira Amraoui en
voiture elles sont toutes les deux
joueuses voilà pour les téléspectateurs
qui les connaîtraient pas moi je les
connaissais pas son coéquipière elles
sont arrêtées par deux hommes cagoulés
et qui rame raoui et frappé à coup de
barre de fer c'est c'est là comment
cette histoire oui effectivement et puis
l'ironie même de l'histoire c'est
qu'elle elle sorte ce soir-là d'un dîner
de cohésion organisé par leur club pour
voilà ressouder l'équipe à quelques
jours d'un match très important de Ligue
des Champions contre le Real Madrid et
effectivement rien ne se passe comme
prévu parce que sur le chemin du retour
Aminata Diallo a proposé ses services
pour accompagner deux de ses
coéquipières qui habitent à Chatou dans
les Yvelines elle habite en un peu plus
loin et parmi ces deux coéquipières il y
a kheimer et donc Aminata Diallo va
d'abord déposer la première et ensuite
alors qu'elle doit aller déposer camaï
là de deux hommes cagoulées surgissent
dans une rue de Chatou voilà où il y a
absolument aucun témoin et l'agression
voilà se déroule sur deux trois minutes
Aminata Diallo et maintenu dans la
voiture immobilisé par l'un des deux
agresseurs tandis que l'autre
extirp keremy de la voiture et la frappe
à coup de barre de fer en visant et
c'est intéressant entre guillemets en
visant les jambes mais ça travaille
depuis alors elle jouait dans le même
club est-ce qu'elles avaient le même
poste oui elles évoluent dans dans
l'entrejeu dans le milieu de terrain du
Paris-Saint-Germain et c'est vrai que
c'est un peu déroutant parce que il est
arrivé dans un dans le passé dans un
passé récent qu'elle joue ensemble sur
sous le maillot du PSG mais c'est vrai
que et voilà et je joue toutes les deux
milieux de terrain et Aminata Diallo va
va se fabriquer aussi une conviction
c'est que karamraoui et sa rivale numéro
et l'empêche de jouer plus régulièrement
sous le maillot du PSG et donc l'empêche
de viser le Graal qui est l'équipe de
France de France et donc ça repose aussi
sur une réalité mais sur une part de
psychologie c'est au-delà du foot c'est
vraiment une fiction on a l'impression
d'être dans une fiction ce que ça n'est
que le début de la ferme
qui est agressé vous nous l'avez dit
pendant que l'agression se produit
Aminata était elle est maintenue dans la
voiture par l'autre agresseur donc
forcément voilà Kera est-ce qu'elle a eu
des soupçons rapidement sur sa
coéquipière alors lors de sa première
audition devant les enquêteurs les
policiers de la BRB de la PSG de
Versailles un brigade de répression du
banditisme elle va c'est vrai confier
des premiers soupçons qui sont pas tout
à fait précis mais elle remarque que ça
que sa coéquipière a emprunté un trajet
assez incohérent elle a fait tout un
crochet pour déposer d'abord l'autre
l'autre coéquipière puis ensuite se
retrouver toute seule ensuite avec il y
a un et en plus elle roule semble-t-il
ça c'est c'est l'impression qu'elle
aimera oui c'est ce qu'elle confie aux
enquêteurs elle trouve que Aminata
Diallo roulait vraiment à faible vitesse
peut-être 10 15 km/h pas comme si comme
si elle savait voilà c'est ce qu'elle
dit en tout cas moi oui comme si elle
est très centait l'attaque qui devait
avoir lieu quelques secondes plus tard
alors
Kira donc raconte toute l'histoire voilà
aux policiers elles s'entendait comment
les deux alors d'après ce que l'on sait
moi je n'étais pas dans le vestiaire
j'ai discuté aussi avec mes mes
collègues du service des sports du
Parisien qui qui m'ont expliqué que en
réalité elles avaient des relations mais
plutôt cordiales de de bonne
coéquipières et il leur arrivait même de
de passer des des moments de vacances
ensemble d'accord donc jamais Keira a
senti une jalousie de la part illuminata
Diallo mais c'est jalousie était aussi
c'est ce que l'on comprend à la lumière
des éléments d'enquête
on comprend qu'il y avait une jalousie
masquée et donc il y avait une volonté
de dissimulation aussi réelles
intentions à l'égard de Kira Amraoui
alors c'est vrai que cette histoire est
folle on va revenir sur les éléments de
l'enquête que vous avez dévoilé hier
soir on va les dévoiler nos
téléspectateurs au départ les policiers
vont aller vers une autre hypothèse et
se demande si ce ne serait pas une
affaire de mœurs sur fond de tromperie
et on a tous entendu parler de cette
affaire kherra Amraoui aurait eu une
liaison avec Erica Abidal ex
international voilà après à l'époque où
elle jouait à Barcelone il joue à
Barcelone aussi et ils se sont
intéressés à ça au départ les policiers
oui parce que cette piste arrive en fait
par Aminata Diallo c'est ce qu'on révèle
aussi avec mes collègues Jérémy family
Jean-Michel décugiste qui ont signé
l'article
on apprend qu'en fait à une nata Diallo
enfin à la fin de sa garde à vue la
première garde à vue on est donc au mois
de novembre 2021 une semaine après
l'agression elle est placée en on a vu
et là elle divulgue l'existence d'une
relation intime entre karamaoui et Eric
et Vidal que les enquêteurs évidemment
ignoraient bien sûr et à partir de là
bon il s'intéresse à cette piste parce
que on peut imaginer voilà que l'épouse
Éric kevinal et puis éventuellement
éventuellement se venger donc dans un
premier temps il vérifie l'existence de
cette relation sentimentale ils ont un
élément matériel c'est Aminata Diallo
qui l'a qui leur parle de ça assez
Aminata Diallo qui les met sur cette
piste d'accord et après ils vont ils
vont essayer de vérifier ils vont
constater que oui effectivement il y a
bien eu une relation intime entre Erica
Vidal et keramaoui Eric et bien lui-même
ne s'engage pas il le reconnaît mais
pour autant en crevant cette piste bien
il se rendent compte que ça ne les
conduit nulle part il n'y a pas dans
l'environnement de l'épouse d'Eric
Abidal de personnes susceptibles d'avoir
d'être impliqué dans dans l'agression
donc ils ont rapidement abandonné cette
piste Gilles voulaient rebondir là
dessus oui ils ont fait
d'autres ils ont exploré d'autres pistes
liées à la vie privée ils ont passé au
crible la vie privée comme ami nata
Diallo avait essimé des indices toute la
vie privée madame Amraoui a été passée
au crible elle en a énormément souffert
on l'a accusé de pire chose et dans sa
vie privée également dans sa vie
professionnelle mais dans sa vie privée
on lui a prêté des liaisons ils ont
exploré ils ont interrogé des tas de
couples pour voir s'il y avait pas une
femme trompée une autre même que Madame
Abidal tu aurais pu être à l'origine des
coups de barre de fer tout à fait et
parce que au moment de l'agression Keram
raoui se souvient que l'un des
agresseurs a évoqué le fait qu'elle
avait pu avoir des liaisons avec des
hommes mariés voilà elle se souvient
homme marié et ça le redit aux
enquêteurs donc finalement ça colle et
et avec la confidence faite parmi nata
Diallo donc les enquêteurs forcément
travail cette piste bien sûr et ça mène
nulle part donc en fait c'était une
piste voilà ils avaient lancé une fausse
piste absolument voilà pour pour essayer
de de voilà d'ici peu les soupçons
Aminata Diallo finalement semble bien
avoir été la commanditaire de
l'agression
donc elle aurait fait ça pour vous par
jalousie on va voir son avocat dans un
instant l'hypothèse c'est l'hypothèse
des enquêteurs et des magistrats
il pointe en fait une une dérive une
voilà une rivalité sportive qui serait
devenu une fixation une fixette dans la
dans l'esprit dominata Diallo et qu'il
aurait conduite sur une voilà une dérive
psychologique et même pathologique c'est
en tout cas l'analyse que font les
enquêteurs pour et pour écarter et bien
du PSG et de l'équipe de France c'est
l'hypothèse en tout cas après est-ce
qu'elle avait fait d'autres choses avant
d'autres choses de répréhensibles vous
voulez dire non même voilà des petits il
semblerait que non il semblerait qu'elle
n'est pas manigancée quoi que ce soit
les garde
auparavant en fait les enquêteurs
comprennent qu'il y a un déclic
psychologique dans la tête d'Aminata
Diallo c'est aussi ce qu'on a découvert
nous on travaille sur sur ce sujet au
Parisien c'est que quelques semaines
avant il y a un rassemblement de
l'équipe de France et ça pour Aminata
Diallo comme pour toutes les joueuses et
pour tous les joueurs de football c'est
c'est le sommet c'est le top bien sûr et
Keram ah oui et convoqué pas Aminata
Diallo bon déception de la part
d'Aminata Diallo et finalement carrément
oui est blessé et voilà et et Aminata
Diallo va la remplacer au pied levé
et là elle se rend compte que il y a
effectivement une relation de cause à
effet entre l'absence de keramaoui et
elle sa participation à l'équipe de
France
et que Benjamin Castaldi prend ma place
voilà c'est ça
les policiers ont mis sur écoute la PJ
de Versailles sont véhicule sans
domicile tous ces téléphones et on
retrouve au fil des mois cette haine qui
va monter pour Madame Amraoui de la part
de Aminata Diallo et elle refait toute
l'histoire dit par exemple un jour en
octobre 2021 j'ai marqué un but c'est la
seule qui ne m'a pas félicité c'est
grave tout le monde était content pour
moi et ainsi de suite et c'est vrai que
ça devient une fixation une en et dans
le rapport d'enquête qui est publié là
ce soir il y a tout le déroulé de cette
haine qui monte et ça devient une
obsession pour elle alors vous allez
nous en parler dans un instant un
rapport d'enquête parce qu'il y a
l'avocat qui va arriver dans cette
affaire il y a un personnage qui semble
être au coeur de tout c'est César aime
c'est un proche d'Aminata Diallo et
agent officieux de plusieurs joueuses du
PSG alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire dans
cette affaire effectivement lui c'est un
euh il est dans l'environnement de la
section féminine du PSG il a même un
rôle très important puisqu'il est le
compagnon de l'une des joueuses majeures
de l'équipe et il est aussi agent
officieux de l'attaquant star de
l'équipe qui marrait-antoinette Katoto
c'est ça voilà donc il a il a un rôle
dans la coulisse il a un rôle important
et il était aussi le conseiller l'agent
officieux là encore parce qu'il n'a pas
l'étiquette d'agent il n'a pas le la
licence mais il est il est le conseiller
d'Aminata Diallo et les enquêteurs
réalisent tout ça en exploitant les les
les téléphones et puis on les plaçant
sur écoute et même en sonorisant
l'appartement et la voiture daminata
Diallo ils comprennent que que Aminata
Diallo a une relation intime mais dans
le sens qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont unis
par une par une connivence impacte pour
atteindre des objectifs bien précis des
objectifs financiers c'est à dire que
Aminata Diallo elle veut obtenir un
nouveau contrat c'est ça la clé de
l'énigme en fait la clé de la faire
c'est qu'elle veut un nouveau contrat de
travail avec le PSG et donc
elle aurait pu intercéder auprès des
dirigeants du PSG pour
obtiennent sa prolongation de contrat
d'accord voilà c'est une question en
tout cas qui se sont posées mais ça ça
repose sur quoi ça repose sur les
déclarations interceptées là encore par
les policiers les déclarations d'Aminata
Diallo et de son conseiller il semblait
selon eux bénéficier du soutien de la
maman de Kylian Mbappe c'est en tout cas
ce qui déclarait aux uns aux autres et
ça évidemment les les gens les
dirigeants du PSG le savait ils en
avaient eu vent et donc c'était tout ça
étant peut-être un jeu d'influence là
encore pour pour obtenir le le fameux
contrat la fameuse prolongation de
contrat alors après le retour de
blessure de Kira Amraoui en janvier
Aminata Diallo va continuer de s'en
prendre à elle oui alors bon il y a des
choses qui sont limpides claires dans
cette histoire d’autres qui le sont
moins ce que Aminata Diallo a fait
exactement à partir du mois de janvier
moi je vous le dis franchement Cyril je
l'ignore un peu en revanche il y a il y
a un événement sur des événements très
précis on voit que
Diallo semble toujours animée par une
haine féroce et profonde contre
keramrawi elle est par exemple il y a un
événement qu'on raconte aussi dans Le
Parisien c'est c'est quelques jours
avant un match important Ligue des
Champions une demi-finale contre contre
Lyon et là elle est elle est écurée que
Keram ah oui soit probablement titulaire
c'est son conseiller César m qui lui
apprend la nouvelle parce que césarienne
il a des infos de partout il est hyper
informé donc il lui dit bah tiens toi tu
vas tu vas pas jouer mais en revanche
qui Rama oui elle va jouer l'autre [ __ ]
elle sera titulaire c'est un truc de
malade [ __ ] elle vient pas aux
entraînements elle casse les couilles au
match même au match et voilà et ça ça la
met horsel et et et on comprend aussi à
travers une écoute quel regrette que ses
coéquipières autour d'elle ne fasse rien
ne fasse rien pour elle et que
finalement elle est vraiment ah oui
bénéficier des choix de l'entraîneur
c'est césarienne qui lui dit ça c'est
César m qui s'apprend quelques
titulaire et ça crée une réaction chez
chez Aminata et là très troubl et elle
regrette que la que ses coéquipières
restent les bras croisés ne fasse pas
grand chose et voilà et deux jours plus
tard il se passe quoi il se passe une
bagarre à l'entraînement dans laquelle
keramaoui est impliqué il y a trois
coéquipières autour d'elle et là
karamaoui dérape un peu parce qu'elle
est aussi peut-être provoquée et ça
s'entraîne quoi s'entraîne son exclusion
de l'équipe et finalement ne participent
pas au match donc les enquêteurs
comprennent que les stratagèmes qu'il
semble développer Aminata Diallo et ses
arènes ont des effets dans la vie réelle
du club c'est ça alors on va
accueillir tout de suite l'avocat
d'Aminata Diallo qui est avec nous ce
soir c'est mettre Mourad bathique qui
est là et c'est vrai qu'il va nous
expliquer aussi où on est l'affaire ce
qu'elle risque et ce qu'il en pense la
version exactement
merci Mourad
moi Baptiste qui vient souvent nous voir
et c'est vrai que donc aujourd'hui
Aminata Diallo vient d'être remise en
liberté ce contrôle judiciaire mais
reste accusé d'avoir commandité
l'agression de sa coéquipière merci
encore d'être là maître moi de bâti
merci de venir nous voir à chaque fois
alors votre client terminata Diallo se
dit innocente aujourd'hui oui elle se
dit innocente et moi je voudrais dire je
viens d'entendre encore beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites qui sont
globalement les mêmes que celles qui
sont dites depuis plusieurs heures
depuis plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
semaines depuis même plusieurs mois et
je voudrais quand même dire l'honneur
qui est le mien aujourd'hui de défendre
Aminata Diallo parce que c'est une femme
c'est une joueuse professionnelle un
haut niveau qui a sacrifié sa vie pour
le football et qui est sali lynché mis à
l'index pointé du doigt depuis
96 heures c'est un déferlement ça fait
96 heures de ça fait 96 heures qu'elle
était en art carcération provisoire et
qu'elle fait l'objet d'un acharnement
médiatique
à son encontre et avant elle et ce que
je viens d'entendre et ce que je oui
enfin c'est pas parce que
quand même
a été l'objet d'un enchaîne médiatique
le mécaniquement on parle du lynchage
médiatique
on va procéder par étape la violence
c'est pas donc oui
je vais quand même procéder victime oui
nata Diallo elle lynchait dans les
médias depuis plusieurs jours depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est absolument
inacceptable et moi je veux dire
que ceux qui la pointe du doigt qui la
met à l'index et qui veulent qu'elles ne
se relève pas et bien ça n'arrivera pas
de sitôt parce que les raccourcis
intellectuels les la mauvaise foi vous
êtes vous vous êtes
convaincu qualitynocent je suis
aujourd'hui convaincu qu'elle est
innocence elle clament son innocence et
il n'y a aujourd'hui dans le dossier
rien qui ne permette de relier Aminata
Diallo aux agresseurs et à l'agression
qui a subi kaïra Amraoui j'entends les
écoutes même pas les écoutes évidemment
que les écoutes ça n'est évidemment pas
un élément
n'aurait jamais commandité l'agression
il n'y a aucun élément matériel et qui
nous permettent les recherches on va
prendre les leur expliquer
sur son ordinateur des éléments de
recherche et comme quoi il y avait par
exemple cassé une rotule donc je voulais
savoir si ça n'avait aucun lien ou s'il
y avait juste une coïncidence en fait
si vous voulez ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui
dans le dossier ce sont des éléments
partiels et qui ont fait l'objet d'un
choix très partiel et donc vous avez pu
voir effectivement ces recherches qui
sont sorties dans la presse donc d'abord
on a dit kaminata Diallo c'est pas faux
en fait dites-nous clairement alors
dites-nous parce qu'en fait vous tourner
autour du pot vous êtes très courageux
de devenir ici et je vous en fait ici
parce que tout le monde a besoin d'un
avocat et a le droit d'avoir un avocat
et donc c'est formidable qu'elle est un
avocat mais malgré tout et un bon avocat
sans doute mais elle a cherché ça où
elle n'a pas cherché ça c'est à dire
est-ce que l'article du Parisien est un
tissu de mensonge est-ce que les écoutes
de la police c'est juste du bide elle
disait quoi alors
madame reprend les les conclusions des
officiers de police judiciaire qui est
un résumé donc si vous voulez qu'on
aille au résumé voilà ce qui est un
résumé de plusieurs et long comme résumé
oui mais vous savez monsieur vous savez
qu'il pas de dans ce dossier 37 pages
vous savez ce que combien il y a de
codes dans ce dossier il y a énormément
il y a plusieurs centaines de pages
plusieurs centaines ah non plusieurs
milliers et peut-être même plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'accord donc c'est
un résumé
donc un résumé on a un résumé très à
charge vous venez de le dire
effectivement nous avons un résumé très
à charge on peut reprendre point par
point pour que ce soit un peu plus clair
il y a effectivement une recherche qui a
été faite qui n'est pas celle qui a été
dit dans les médias à savoir comment
casser une rotule ça n'est jamais elle
n'a jamais fait la recherche de savoir
comment casser une rotule il y a une
recherche qui a été faite sur casser une
rotule sauf que si vous voulez si on
prend cet élément là sans exploiter les
recherches qui ont été faites avant et
les recherches qui ont été faites après
on peut faire dire à peu près n'importe
quoi si j'exploité votre téléphone Cyril
et que je prenais un élément très précis
pour vouloir lui faire dire ce que je
veux en dire j'y parviendrai la dernière
recherche c'est comment bouffer un cul
elle se raconter une histoire celle-là
était justifié ce que je sais ce que je
sais pour être pour être un tout petit
peu sérieux parce que elle a été
incarcérée pendant quatre jours et
désolé de prendre ce dossier très au
service
il y a un individu un joueur de foot qui
s'appelle Jordan marié qui faisait son
retour le 23 octobre quelques jours
avant cette recherche d'Aminata Diallo
qui joue qui joue caler son match
devinez où à Grenoble doué originaire
Aminata Diallo de Grenoble et devinez ce
qui est arrivé à ce monsieur casser la
Jordan marié il sait pas casser la jambe
il s'est cassé la rotule et il parle de
sa rotule en disant ma rotule est en
angle droit donc moi je donc
je sais pas si c'est je sais pas si
c'est dû à ça mais je dis que c'est
quand même étrange d'avoir
des éléments successifs les uns à la
suite des autres qui ne sont que des
éléments à charge et ce que j'ai entendu
sur ce plateau avant d'intervenir ça
n'était que des éléments à charge et ça
pose quand même un problème je crois
qu'il faut que l'équilibre des armes
soit respecté alors je crois qu'une
enquête pour qu'elle soit audible doit
être menée à charge et à décharge et
pour vous les victimes Aminata Diallo
alors pour moi Aminata Diallo est
d'abord innocente
innocente et effectivement elle a été
pour rien
elle est pour rien dans ce dossier donc
vraiment pour vous
ce n'est l'erreur judiciaire pour
l'instant
parce que pour l'instant on est dans la
phase de l'instructions
vous allez Cyril je crois que c'est
enfin on peut monter en épingle et faire
croire des choses en prenant des
extraits ici et là je crois que si on
regarde vos téléphones respectifs ici
autour de ce bateau je n'ai pas fini ma
phrase je n'ai pas fini ma phrase bah
c'est très difficile de contre
argumenter sur quelque chose que j'ai
pas encore dit donc je crois que si on
prenait les téléphones de chacun ici
autour de ce plateau et bien il y aurait
des choses pas très jolies entre les
animateurs il y aurait des choses dans
le cadre privé qui serait dite qui
serait pas très jolie et dans le cadre
des compétitions sportives de haut
niveau dans le cadre des compétitions
sportives de haut niveau évidemment que
vous alliez dans le foot dans le rugby
dans le tennis et dans tous les sports
de haut niveau je veux dire ça n'est pas
et la mettre dans l'huile par exemple tu
dis ça dans le rapport de c'est pas sur
l'affaire c'est avant
mais c'est avant ça dénote quand même
personne
qui peut entretenir de la haine
êtes-vous individuellement et
collectivement des béni-oui Oui-Oui vous
descendez de quelle planète parce que
dans le monde du sport je croyais pas
d'aller révélation
dans l'huile moi mettre hein
en vous disant que si vous allez dans
les vestiaires du Real de Madrid de
Barcelone chez les grands tennisman chez
les grands nageurs il y a des choses pas
très jolies qui sont dit entre les
personnes qui sont en couple maintenant
je n'ai pas de temps à perdre je suis
patiente mais il ne faut rien laisser
passer là on a l'impression quand même
mettre qu'elle est elle se met en compte
ce que vous dites ce que vous dites est
absurde par exemple
des policiers qui fait 37 pages qui
résument les écoutes donc de du véhicule
et du domicile d'Aminata Diallo votre
cliente maître et donc dans c'est après
l'agression après l'agression voilà je
te parle pour maintenant je n'ai pas de
temps à perdre je suis patient qu'il ne
faut rien laisser passer il faut lire
tout de suite fini la défense et cetera
et cetera très agressive etc dites-nous
exactement un élément vous avez pas
d'éléments on peut prendre d'autres
éléments prenez-moi des éléments dit
elle dit d'un membre du staff de son
club tu le ce fils de [ __ ] races le
jusqu'au dernier centime près elle parle
de qui
Monsieur Bruno chérou mais alors on est
sur caerraoui on est sur quelqu'un
d'autre là
des notes une personnalité on utilise
des mots et qui est prête à aller très
loin au moins dans les mots contre des
gens qui l'empêchent qui l'empêche de
briller mais il n'empêche de rien du
tout au moment de l'agression Aminata
Diallo est titulaire au moment de
l'agression Aminata Dalio Diallo est
appelé en équipe de France je vous
rappelle que kaïra ramraoui n'a pas joué
en équipe de France depuis trois ans
donc vous voyez que toute la théorie
toute la fable que vous nous servez à
longueur de journée je parle pas de vous
personnellement mais je parle de tous
ceux qui ont écrit des tissus de
mensonges sur Aminata Diallo ça n'est
pas la réalité vous allez porter plainte
alors contre le Parisien ah bah c'est
c'est une option qui est fortement
c'est une option qui est clairement
envisagée et je le dis de manière
peut-être un peu plus claire pour que
les propos soient dit tout ce qui
souhaiteraient à l'avenir dire des
choses fausses à l'encontre de ma
cliente qui prendrait des raccourcis
intellectuels et qui
près du doigt sur des éléments factuels
font ici ou là oui il y aura une réponse
judiciaire est-ce qu'il y a eu la
recherche sur Google Maps cocktail de
médicaments dangereux alors je sais pas
s'il y a eu cette recherche qui est
sorti aussi ça il faudra vérifier encore
une fois faut vérifier ce qui a été
recherché avant après parce que si dans
les minutes qui ont suivi ou qui ont
précédé elle avait fait une recherche
sur le doliprane maux de tête bah vous
voyez que la recherche qu'on exume comme
ça en disant ah bah voilà on a la
coupable idéale vous voyez qu'elle
serait toute relative alors est-ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est-ce qu'il a
jamais voulu du mal à sa coéquipier pour
vous que jamais alors moi pour moi elle
a pas voulu de mal en tout cas de elle a
jamais voulu attendre à son intégrité
physique et je mets au défi
n'importe qui autour de sa table de
prouver et de m'avancer un élément
matériel qui permettrait de le prouver
maintenant effectivement dans ce groupe
elles étaient cinq ou six pour deux ou
trois postes en milieu de terrain donc
évidemment qui avait une forme de
concurrence non pas la concurrence qu'on
a souhaité présenter mais une forme de
concurrence c'est à dire une concurrence
d'un point de vue sportif
sur le dossier sauf erreur de ma part
l'homme qui a porté les coups en ce
moment est encore en fuite est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord là-dessus mais mais
les deux personnes qui étaient là ce
soir-là ont ciblé on cite madame Diallo
comme celle qui aurait comment dire le
le fait de taper à coup de barre de fer
sur Madame sur ce point là vous avez
parfaitement raison et alors je vous
l'explique alors d'abord la personne qui
a mis les coups de barre de fer est
aujourd'hui en détention provisoire
d'accord la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que ça fait 10 mois qu'on
explique que Aminata Diallo elle a
coupable idéal caminata Diallo a
probablement fomenté cette agression etc
aujourd'hui le commanditaire n'est pas
arrêté l'intermédiaire n'est pas arrêté
ça c'est factuel c'est en procédure on
ne sait pas aujourd'hui personne n'est
capable ni du côté de l'acquisition ni
du côté du ministère public ni côté de
la BRB de la police judiciaire de
Versailles ou du magistrat instructeur
personne n'est capable de dire qui est
l'intermédiaire que l'on désire je vous
explique juste ce point très important
qui est cette intermédiaire qui a envoyé
les quatre jeunes agresseurs ça personne
ne sait qui est cette personne
aujourd'hui et bien cette personne elle
a tout le loisir de convoquer les quatre
gamins en disant ben écoutez si un jour
vous faites attraper on est bien
d'accord que c'est Aminata Diallo parce
que elle revêt aujourd'hui le visage du
coupable idéal et ça factuellement
personne ne sait aujourd'hui qui est
l'intermédiaire qui a envoyé ces quatre
gamins aujourd'hui vous avez énormément
parlé forcément avec votre cliente elle
a été elle est souvent sous contrôle
judiciaire elle est placé sous contrôle
judiciaire qu'est-ce qui a dit qu'est-ce
qu'on dit les enquêteurs pourquoi ils
l'ont ils l'ont ils l'ont relâché
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui c'est ce
juge des libertés de la détention qui a
estimé au regard du dossier au regard
des garanties de représentation que nous
avons présenté aujourd'hui avec mon
confrère romain Ruiz et ma sœur Chloé
Redon que il y avait suffisamment de
garantie de représentation pour
permettre à dire des garanties de
représentation ça veut dire qu'on sait
que elle ne fuira pas le territoire
contre elle se présentera aux
intervalistes aux auditions etc et donc
que l'enquête peut se poursuivre
sereinement parce que je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui elle est présumée
innocente c'est quand même pas rien et
on balaye pas ça dans Reverso c'est
quand même le redire et on le redis
présumé innocente pour donc on a une
enquête pour une enquête qui est
conduite par un magistrat instructeur et
donc il va se poursuivre encore pendant
6 mois huit mois dix mois un an et au
cours desquels des actes et des éléments
à charge viendront peut-être s'ajouter
et une fois des pas coutume des éléments
à décharge que nous présenterons du côté
de la défense alors pour vous qui avez
énormément discuté avec elle vous a
raconté toute son histoire
il n'y a aucun doute à liquide à être
innocente moi je vous dis juste
simplement à mon sens moi ce que je
porte et je porte sa défense et je crois
foncièrement dans l'innocence d'Aminata
Diallo et j'y crois pas simplement parce
que je suis son avocat j'y crois parce
que ça fait 5 jours depuis vendredi que
nous sommes du matin au soir au tribunal
judiciaire de Versailles et que nous
avons eu le dossier de fond en comble
depuis 5 jours et la raison pour
laquelle je crois en son innocence c'est
qu'au bout de cinq jours contrairement à
ce qui a été dit dans les médias où on
extrait un bout de phrase pour en faire
dire un énorme paragraphe et bien
contrairement à ce qui a été dit il n'y
a pas d'éléments matériels qui relie
Aminata Diallo à l'agression qui a été
formantée contre Keira hamraoui Ronan
personne ne dit le contraire et surtout
surtout pas personne ne me dérange mais
surtout personne ne le dit non mais
quand même important de le dire à un
moment ça a été écrit dans notre article
il n'y a pas effectivement la preuve
d'un lien matériel comme vous dites
entre Minata Diallo et les agresseurs
qui ont été
identifiés après
il y a
c'est la lecture en tout cas que que
font les enquêteurs il y a de la part
des Minata Diallo un mobile clair qui
est constitué qui a été lié c'est ce
mobile financier le mobile de la
jalousie aussi à l'égarder le mot
financier je vous rappelle qu'à ce
moment-là Aminata Diallo est titulaire
au Paris Saint-Germain qui est pas un
petit club qui est quand même une
institution elle est titulaire au Paris
Saint-Germain elle a été rappelée en
équipe de France elle a fait deux matchs
contre le Kazakhstan et je ne sais plus
quel autre faveur de la blessure à la
faveur
ne jouez pas en équipe de France n'était
pas sélectionnée elle était absente
depuis un an ou trois ans depuis 3 ans
elle n'a pas joué en équipe de France
vous voyez que ce qu'on explique on
essaye d'imaginer une fable selon
laquelle elle serait en compétition un
peu comme dans le patinage artistique il
y aurait deux places pour un passe ça
n'est pas le cas ça n'est pas le cas
argument financiers cher monsieur je le
balai d'un revers de main elle est
titulaire au Paris Saint-Germain elle
est pressentie pour être prolongée
pendant deux ans par le Paris
Saint-Germain je veux dire tous les
signaux sont ouverts et ça n'est pas
faire offense et ça n'est pas faire
offense à kairamraoui de dire que
kaïraoui avec 32 ans j'avais 32 ans elle
était peut-être sur un déclin sportif
alors caminata Diallo c'est en peine
expansion